meet pepper the robot pepper has been
given many tasks during a short time in
existence but now you'll even find him
in a robe and chanting sutras at Japan's
largest funeral and cemetery Expo the
robots creator programmed pepper to
fulfill religious duties that are
increasingly neglected in society many
priests have begun taking up part-time
jobs in order to get by but that means
that they don't have time to read the
Sutra to Buddha in the morning and at
night so we thought that pepper could
fill that role of worship although
pepper costs a quarter of what human
priests cost some expressed doubt that a
robot could carry out religious tasks
the ultimate criterion is whether or not
we're able to impart the spiritual
aspect to the Machine I believe that the
Spirit is the foundation of religion I'm
here because I wanted to see whether or
not pepper is able to embody that pepper
will be singing sutras to Buddha at the
Tokyo International Exhibition Center
until the 25th of August